is taking extreme ownership the same as
apologizing for failures or apologizing
for others mistakes I'm having
difficulty separating these two concepts
when I try to take ownership over
failures does taking ownership of
failure generally include and I'm sorry
X occurred etc second well it isn't just
apologizing right it isn't just saying
oh I apologize this happened it's part
of it part of ownership is apologizing
if you make a mistake you got to own it
and generally you gotta say hey look I'm
sorry this happened you got to own that
there's been a problem or a mistake or
an issue and that does include other
people's mistakes but you have to
literally take ownership of them you
can't say hey I'm sorry these other
people made mistakes that's not what I'm
talking about
and it's look the mistakes that were
made were actually my fault and another
important thing here is you can't just
say hey guys it's all my fault
you actually need to mean it and you
need to believe it yourself you need to
believe that you failed in the situation
to do the right thing or make something
happen or make the right decision or
make the right call and do the right
preparation or whatever it is that you
were supposed to do you need to do that
you need to believe that you can't just
say it and you say these mistakes were
my fault here's why it was my fault and
yeah I'm sorry that these things happen
I apologize with this happening and some
people see sorry as a sign of weakness
and honestly there's some you know some
legal situations you might be in or some
negotiations that you might be in where
that might be true but most the time as
we're seeing a working environment the
inside of a team sorry is okay in fact
an apology is often the first step in
moving forward right and and it's
generally gonna be a little bit of a
blow to your ego now and that's
especially true because
you're mr. extreme ownership now or mrs.
extreme ownership guess what that
doesn't mean everyone else is not yet no
get there but they're not there yet so
you apologize to someone it's gonna be a
big blow to your ego especially when
someone says you're damn right that was
your fault mm-hmm
that's that's gonna hurt you you're
gonna want to lash back out but you
can't mm-hmm got to put your ego in
check and you gotta go hey I understand
it is my fault
you know why I'm saying it's my fault
because I truly believe it was my fault
it is because it is your fault so you
got to be careful when someone gloats
don't let that get your head what that's
what you have to do and it's not just
not just for you that you're doing this
it's cuz the team because the team has
to figure out what the problem is
someone's got to take ownership of the
problem that's you and then that's how
you get the problem solved and I'll tell
you something else and you might have
predicted this but my sorry and my
apology comes with something else
99% of the time and that's a good right
so look
hey I'm sorry that this happened this is
my fault but I'm glad it happened now oh
yeah hey you know what
I'm glad we made this mistake we made
this mistake right now it's gonna set us
back a little bit good because we're now
we're not gonna make it with a client no
oh this happened this part of the
project fell apart good now he can fix
it and we know about it oh this went
sideways I missed it good I won't let it
happen again
so throw yourself a little good on the
end of your sari all right yeah a lot of
times those problems or mistakes or
whatever the they add to that experience
like the experience of being there you
know where we're let's say you go
through a path and you make a wrong turn
now you have that experience that that's
the wrong turn that's what that looks
like that look that's what that feels
like and guess what we're gonna avoid
that in the future rather than a bunch
of situation where it we're for example
one in the future where it's more
detrimental now you don't run into that
you learned you learned we got a video
that said there beat you learned